eyewitnesses describe a plane on fire
lighting up the night sky the crash of
an antonov cargo plane tearing through
an open field
i wonder how it didn't fall on our
houses because it came from over there
it was full of smoke it had a noise i
can't describe and went over the
mountain it passed the mountain and
turned and crashed into the fields there
were flames we were scared a lot of cars
came but they could not approach because
there were continuous explosions
the scale of devastation at first
confusing people who saw the plane come
down
we see something bright coming down from
the direction of the castle but we
thought it was a light
after that we said fire fire what is it
is it a plane what is it
by the time we understood what it was it
had fallen to the ground we were
terrified we also had children we were
screaming shouting
local residents and first responders
describe ongoing explosions following
the crash
it crashed to the ground and developed
into a large fire with many continuous
explosions
greek media reports hazardous materials
were on board including explosives
the matrices of this thing
the air measurements at the moment have
not shown anything but nonetheless
instability in the field was observed in
other words intense smoke and heat as
well as a white substance that we do not
recognize so a special armed forces team
has to inform us of what it is and
whether we can enter the field
the flight was operated by meridian a
ukraine-based cargo carrier it
originated in serbia the country's
defense ministry confirming the cargo
the plane was carrying 11.5 tons of
products of our arms trade for the end
buyer in bangladesh the buyer was the
bangladesh ministry of defense as a
fully permitted end user and buyer the
flight route was niss with technical
landings in amman riyad ahmedabad and
was planned to land in dhaka as the
final destination
moments before the plane went down the
pilot radioed about a problem with one
of the engines requesting an emergency
landing but unable to make it to the
nearest airport the journey ending in a
field in northern greece
zayn basravi al-jazeera
david arosh is an associate professor
and senior military fellow at the
national defense university he says
examining the scene is difficult because
of explosives in the wreckage
11.5 tons sounds like a lot it's it's
not a whole lot for arms shipments the
reason why it was flown rather than sent
by sea is because it's uh you know not
big enough for a ship you know and
obviously if you're shipping weapons you
have to have a dedicated ship just for
that um
it's a problem when you have explosives
because uh when the plane crashes you
have to worry about the explosives
cooking off afterwards so uh the damage
always looks worse because people don't
go and put out the fire they have to sit
back let the fire burn itself out and uh
you know it's it's always unpleasant
it's always nasty uh when a plane
crashes but this is particularly
unpleasant because of that
they also they're also reports that some
of the rounds were mortar illumination
rounds which are not normal uh you know
blast explosives they tend to be
metallized uh finely fragmented pieces
of metal which are extremely flammable
so again that would create some problems
for uh firefighters and rescuers
ukraine is among the world air leaders
in air cargo services uh they produce or
they did until the russians destroyed
the factory uh you know wide-body
aircraft nato countries charter uh
aircraft from the ukrainian firms uh
quite frequently they they are among the
world leaders so this isn't some shady
fly by night it's an established uh well
well-accepted practice
although you know they're not subject to
some of the scrutiny that a western
country would be they're not part of any
european institutions but uh they are a
known quantity
uh the initial report said mortars and
mines and i think they meant more rounds
i know that there's trace elements of
you know illuminating radioactive
material sometimes in mortar sites that
you could view at night the same as you
get in wristwatch
if there's any kind of toxic substances
the greek government probably
consolidates all of that under their on
their uh energy authority and i think it
makes sense to at least scan it because
low-level radiation is used not in
munitions but in some military equipment
tanvir chowdhury has more on the
government's response in bangladesh's
capital dhaka the plane's final
destination
well i spoke to the inter-service public
relations office was essentially the
media wing of the defense ministry and
the armed forces combined together now
they hand out a statement in bangla to
local media as well as to me saying this
plane was carrying essentially uh
ammunition for mortars for bangladesh
army and the border guards for training
purposes now that contradicts little bit
with the serbian defense minister what
he was saying that includes weapons and
mines now the definition of weapons and
ammunition can be a little bit confusing
but one thing for sure that bangladesh
admitted that plane was ukrainian
registered cargo plane was destined for
bangladesh we still have to find out
what's the greek authorities after they
investigated exactly find out what was
in that plane bangladesh traditionally
since its independent have been buying
weapons from previous or former soviet
bloc countries traditionally russia
yugoslavia czech republic and now serbia
is one of the suppliers of bangladesh
buys artillery pieces from them from
belu russia most of the weapons purchase
are russian grades although majority are
supplied by china and many of them are
used in the u.n peacekeeping operation
bangladesh is one of the largest troops
contingent in the u.n so many of this
weapon are used overseas in different
peacekeeping missions traditionally
they've been using eastern bloc weapons
as opposed to western bloc weapons so
the serbian weapon supply is not so
surprising uh although in this case
we're a little confused on it was just
semination or just weapons